vicky bowman once the uk's top diplomat
in myanmar is now in jail charged
alongside her husband taylin a burmese
artist and former political prisoner
with breaking visa rules
a statement from the junta the military
government said from may the 4th 2021 to
august the 10th 2022 ten lin and his
wife did not reside at the registered
residence
bowman has spent decades in the country
and i regularly find myself in a yangon
taxi talking to the driver i'm an
english girl i married a burmese man and
they go ah can't light her and i say
please put your hands back on the
steering wheel
she runs the myanmar center for
responsible business aimed at
encouraging companies to adhere to
international human rights standards but
campaigners believe she is the one who
now needs help
she is now one of over 15 000 people
that have been arrested in burma since
the military coup and i think it just
goes to show that absolutely no one is
safe in burma while this military remain
in charge if the military are trying
this as some kind of
hostage diplomacy then we've got to make
sure that doesn't work you know the
british government can't be blackmailed
into dropping pressure it needs to
increase pressure one diplomat who also
did the job is fearful
i don't think it's genuine at all it's
at
worst a an infringement of a very
technical law part of the immigration
law so i don't think the um arrests
would be considered necessary in um in
most countries
it is a nation riven with internal
fighting 18 months after the military
seized power in a coup
one followed by a bloody crackdown
the uk has just imposed fresh sanctions
to target military-linked companies
there
one activist told sky news vicki bowman
considers herself to be neutral
she's now at the mercy of the junta
facing up to five years in prison if
she's found guilty
cordelia lynch sky news bangkok